what am I doing oh you people stop it
stop it don't stop [ __ ] but I'm kidding
happy Wednesday so we're just five days
into Kevin McCarthy's tenure as Speaker
of the House and he's already become my
favorite Kevin
well uh behind Kevin Spacey
and as you know it's always preferable
to be behind Kevin Spacey
of course
it took 15 ballots to confirm McCarthy
which coincidentally is the same amount
it took Biden to become president
yeah Sue me
but while the house was Voting and
re-voting McCarthy was proving that
Revenge much like the fruity pebbles
Bill hemmer feeds me in the morning
is a dish best served cold
what's different this time Republicans
learn something from Trump they're
keeping their promises and fighting like
fiends on Tuesday they took steps to
boost oversight of both the Chinese
government and the Biden Administration
granted it's hard to tell the two apart
laughs
first they approved a new subcommittee
designed to probe the weaponization of
the federal government you know I hate
that word weaponization it's overused
just say exactly what you're
investigating abuses against the
American people does the government
collect info on or otherwise
investigating in the sense of citizens
of the U.S and how deep was that
collusion between the FBI and private
sectors to ban speech that the White
House disagreed with House Republicans
also called him a plan to address
threats from China like fentanyl attacks
on the power grid an underspiced bat
soup
the GOP is also clawing back billions in
IRS funding that would have financed 87
000 new employees to harass Freelancers
small businesses and the orphans who
manage my offshore bank accounts
rest in peace orphans
if Biden wants to get blood from a stone
he should do a face plant while bike
riding again
but all that probably wasn't even the
best thing McCarthy did this week yes
it's time to
isn't it
Bliss
we're going away
those
politicians around
and now they can't stay
[Music]
send out the clouds
[Applause]
please leave a lot
[Music]
you get to Live Another Day Gene
Yep this week he booted hacks ilhan Omar
Adam Schiff and Eric swalwell from their
house committees
the bright spot for Omar when she breaks
the bad news to her husband and her
brother she'll only have to make one
phone call
never gets old yeah
that's for swalwell McCarthy promised to
come after him and unlike the flatul and
flunky it wasn't just hot air he says
well well can't get a security clearance
in the private sector I'm not going to
give him a government security clearance
but in suelo's defense no one would hire
him in the private sector
Pro tip Eric if a beautiful woman is in
is interested in you she's either a spy
a hooker or has lost her sense of smell
finally it's true there's this hapless
Harlequin Adam Schiff who's manufactured
more lies than the Cosmetic industry
McCarthy vows we will not allow him to
be on the intelligence committee either
I would also add anything else that has
the word intelligence in the title we
asked Adam Schiff to comment
hmm I may no longer be chairman but I
can still feel like one with my new
strap-on Chairman's high back chair
whether walking the dog
pretty good getting the mail
bills
or just adding
fun
beached
nicely done
good right I didn't see that
so McCarthy said he'd retaliate for the
removal of Republicans from their
assignments in the last Congress and he
did up next investigating the Biden
family for their alleged crimes which
include authentic collusion and
countless Shady foreign dealings the
only one who doesn't think the big guy
is Biden is Joe Biden
because he stopped thinking in 1992.
so does this kind of Tit for Tat slow
down Congress the answer is I hope so
keep it busy
keep them busy fighting each other it
keeps them out of our Lives while
they're slapping the crap out of each
other we get to continue to do fun
things like cooking on gas stoves and
drinking shark fin shakes through a
plastic straw
but also every time Congress agrees on
something we get more war and more debt
and if the weasels know they're always
just a midterm away from getting busted
maybe they'll do better and that's what
the winning will get you you get to
stick it to the other side investigate
prosecute the Dems did it last time but
now it's their turn in the barrel and
like I always say payback's at Joy Behar
foreign
[Applause]
comedian Rob Schneider
[Applause]
he might look like a million bucks but
he's just a single Bill America's
Newsroom co-anchor bill hemmer
she's like a nickel shiny small and
often found hiding under a couch cushion
boxes contributor cat Tim
and finally he has trouble seeing eye to
eye with people and giraffes mice
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
how are you Rob I'm good good to be back
it's nice to hear Joe Rogan singing your
Praises yes well you know that I'll be
I'll take anything I can get at this
point you know what I mean I'm a very
lonely man rob
what do you make of this stuff so far
the Omar the ships the swallows going
what's your takeaway well I think that
um I I think McCarthy's right I don't
think he can get a clearance I mean I
don't even think he can get like a
global entry yes you know what I'm
saying like sorry swell well we got to
take you and um Fang bang to go in the
regular line
[Laughter]
where they where they may not know what
do they x-ray your balls get in there
you know
how did he not know that she was a spot
it wasn't a spy who's named Fang Fang
and not a spy
yeah I I don't have an answer for that
he doesn't have an answer for that there
is no answer to that yes there is yes
but it seems like they're fighting the
Republicans are fighting that's good it
is no I think we're you know we're in an
interesting place now where um you know
we actually have an opposition who can
do something which is good it's not by a
lot but there's it's enough and I'll
take I'll take enough right now any
opposition to authoritarianism I don't
care which side you're on let's go for
it exactly there's always you need to
have two sides Bill and you have two
sides
one that's fun and one that's flirty
I don't even know where I am it's kind
of funny seeing Omar getting kicked off
Foreign Affairs while redefining family
Affairs yeah it's interesting and
swallow got kicked off and the but you
know what happened today what an
extraordinary thing happened in
Washington DC they had 365 members of
the House vote for something together
that included 146 Democrats was that for
China that was for the China committee
that McCarthy says should live forever
yeah right on this the way the
competition even swallow voted for it he
knows something about China exactly sure
now on the island if he votes for it
he'll see Fang Fang
it's a possibility yeah I don't know why
America decided to not manufacture
anything anymore yeah so we're just
completely reliant on China I mean can't
we make like you know can we make like a
Minnie Mouse doll here in America does
it have to be made you know by some lead
poison slave in Guangdong China you know
it's true let's make something all the
toy like all the like toy drum sets are
made in China it's like we can't do how
do you know that I do a lot of deep
Dives
at Casey off authorities stop by you
have an unusual search history
a lot of toys it makes a lot of
donations to orphanages Hammer what
what's gonna happen with this China
committee well
um we'll see I mean the house only has
you know one-third of one-third of
government but on the IRS thing I was
thinking what do you do with 87 000 why
do you need 87 000 IRS agents what are
they gonna do all day yeah how are they
going to spend their time you could then
I was thinking Rob you know you got two
million migrants a year now and so you
could send them IRS is going to have
some pressure targets send them to know
you could send the 87 000 to the Border
you know and then try auditing and see
if they want to commend these migrants
if you start auditing them yes
see what happens
[Applause]
Pirates
what are your thoughts on the events
well first of all to answer Bill's
question what are they gonna do with us
that's what they're going to do they're
going to come after us that's and so I'm
glad it's not going to happen but
we get excited but we know what's going
to happen
it's going to get vetoed or as he likes
to say huh so uh
I'm still shocked that he thought the
Salvation Army was the Secret Service
I can't let that go you're you're in a
24-hour
that is not an emergency meeting where
are the generals like
I'll say it again
he fought
the Salvation Army guy
what's the secret service
and everybody's okay with this this
we're numb to it now yeah I mean but
it's beyond the pale like you know and
I'm I think it was great you know
swalwell's best
Greg sometimes love blinds you we've all
been there you know you're always the
last guy to know that she's slept with
everybody else in the football team yes
you know and until the one guy she
didn't tell them no I was usually the
guy who had to break it down to him like
hey man you got a second
come on over here yeah give me a minute
yeah this is going to hurt but um I
thought his line was great it was like
they said I didn't do anything wrong
what's the point you were compromised
just off GP you should be like you know
what I'm not fit because I was
compromised yeah exactly but it's not
about that it's about the money you know
and the Agents the the whole thing about
the IRS agents had nothing to do with
the IRS it was about funding to slide
their money for the uh electronic car
stuff so that's what that was about
interesting last word to you Kat are you
excited do you think it's ever going to
happen in your lifetime the IRS will be
abolished no that's the thing it's it's
nice to say it and it's good for them to
say that this is something they'd like
to see happen but they also know there's
no situation in when this would actually
happen like you said the Biden would
veto it and it wouldn't even get that
far because of the Democrats in the
Senate so it's kind of like when a man
says to you like I would go to the ends
of the Earth for you
it's nice to hear but no one's going to
show up and ask you to do that like this
isn't the Lord of the Rings you can just
take the trash out yes we have to be
super I'd like to see you know work on
things that could potentially happen it
is tough when it's split which isn't the
worst thing but anybody who wouldn't
vote for that then there's something
serious that's true though it's like we
just want you to take out the trash yeah
not like solve world hunger although
that would be nice I would like to see
the IRS abolish but if there was all
Republicans in charge I feel like they
wouldn't have the balls to actually
propose something like that unless they
put at the end of everything they want
done an ice cream party
so he's not going to veto an ice cream
party that is true
ice cream party
abolish the IRS and ice cream for
everyone I want to know about the I want
to know about the the guns for the IRS I
mean yeah where do those go where the
IRS needs guns as much as like strippers
need phds yes although
dude that's the reason why they strip is
to get that PHP you make me sick Mr
Snyder I have funded several Geniuses
exactly
that's right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else